got 10 points here in the fourth quarter
ball turns it over
terence mann beverly for three
let's take
make some noise
[Music]
second half from the la clippers reggie
jackson
and the clippers a superb
third and fourth quarter turning a close
game
into right now a 16 point advantage in
patrick beverly at both ends of the
floor
once again clamping down on devin booker
and the clippers
starting to taste what could be their
first win here in these conference
finals
and reggie jackson going to he's too
small
mark was doing terence man
third team foul
[Music]
patrick beverly clicking on all
cylinders leaving the ball game getting
acknowledged right now
but offensively scoring defensively
disrupting
the crowd showing true appreciation
beverly started the first two games of
the playoffs
and was sent to the bench was out of the
rotation even some games had some
did not play coach's decisions but came
back in the starting lineup
in game two of these conference finals
and his defense
a huge part of the job they've done on
devin booker the last two games
and certainly instrumental especially
without the former defensive player of
the year kawhi leonard
he has led them defensively